ah voilà un sujet passionnant
aujourd'hui se parler d'eux samsung vous
voulez acheter un nouveau smartphone de
samsung mais vous n'avez pas forcément
le qu'elle achetait je vous comprends il
y en a beaucoup c'est relativement
compliqué alors aujourd'hui on se parle
uniquement du haut de gamme on se parle
de la gamme galaxy s chez samsung
il ya beaucoup de gamme vous avez la
gamme galaxy z tout ce qui va se plier
vous avez la gamme galaxy s qui est le
très haut de gamme axée sur la photo et
sur la vidéo vous avez la gamme galaxy
note avec le style est basé sur la
productivité et la performance vous avez
la gamme galaxy à qui correspond à
l'entrée ni de bien vous avez la gamme
et enfin bref il ya beaucoup de gars
c'est le bazar
aujourd'hui on va parler de la gamme
galaxy s pour essayer de comprendre quel
smartphone samsung dans le très haut de
gamme acheter axé sur la photo et sur la
vidéo
[Musique]
5 vous aura pas échappé cette année est
sorti plusieurs modèles vous avez le
samsung galaxy s 21 qui est sorti en
tout début d'année vous avez aussi le s
plus vous avez le s 21 ultra vous avez
ensuite un modèle qui est sorti l'année
dernière dans la deuxième partie de
l'année
c'est le s20 et feu pour fans edition
vous avez sorti en début d'année
dernière le s20 vous avez également le
s20 plus est sorti en début d'année vous
avez le s20 à ultra qui est sorti
également en début d'année dernière et
avant vous aviez les s10 s10 plus s 10es
10 trucs s10 light et avant les s 9
laissé tout ça alors je vous le dis tout
de suite d'emblée tout ce qui va être s8
ls9 on oublie on est trop vieux au
niveau de la performance c'est un
smartphone qui si vous trouvez vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment pas cher et
vous voulez vraiment dans le haut de
gamme smartphone de samsung et du fait
qu'il soit vu ça nous pose un problème
et ben pourquoi pas mais moi en tout cas
j'ai pas bien vouloir commander ici je
veux d'ailleurs vire même m'arrêter là
voyez là c'est juste là tout ce qui va
être s10 s10 plus tac au bar on oublie
ces deux journées une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec rhinochill
parce que oui avoir un très beau
smartphone de la gamme galaxy s c'est
super mais il faut penser à bien le
protège et ça c'est important non chérie
nauche il y en a de tous pour tout le
monde tous les prix et moi je pense tous
vous allez aussi bien avoir des coques
des solides suite avec différentes
finitions différentes décorations quoi
bien même les personnalisées directement
sherin au chili ça c'est super dans
différents univers que ce soit un taux
routeur ce soit fortnight vous avez des
coques approuvé par la nasa
vous avez également des coques sur le
sport la nba league of legends a failli
à plein d'univers différents ça c'est
vraiment vraiment génial sur sa très
jolie d'ailleurs aller jeter un coup
d'oeil je vous mets le lien en bas dans
la description il ya plein d'univers
différents que sérinophile et ça c'est
très très cool si vous souhaitez garder
le dos à parents vous avez également
mode et x vous avez également les crashs
garde venir mettre des bacs play et à
l'arrière pour venir décorer tout ça une
fois de plus dans différents univers et
c'est très chouette vous avez
différentes couleurs pour venir
personnaliser la couleur des boutons
venir match et les couleurs entre elles
comme ça vous venez personnalisé à fond
et ça c'est super chouette et puis
pensez également à venir protéger votre
écran vous
des impacts screen protector qui sont
très cool parce que si vous le faites
tomber sur le dos et ben ça va le
protéger
bien évidemment mais de notre côté pas
forcément donc une fois de plus un pacte
screen protector est chez rhinochill
vous avez aussi plein d'accessoires
différents pour votre smartphone et ça
c'est vraiment super pensez donc à venir
protéger votre samsung galaxy s que vous
aimez temps ou que vous allez bientôt et
n'étant vous ai mis le lien une fois de
plus en bas dans la description et merci
à rhinau shield avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo alors bientôt qui est super
intéressant qu'il faut comprendre dès
maintenant c'est qu'en fait entre le s
s-21 plus et s-21 ultra ce sont une
évolution une amélioration de ce qu'on
avait l'année dernière avec les s20 et
d20 plus s20 ultra on est sur des gammes
de 2000 génération on va dire il n'y a
pas d'énorme évolution ce combat à bord
en termes d'évolution aussi ça va être
effectivement des capteurs photos qui
vont être meilleurs on aura une
amélioration en photo et c'est ce qui va
vraiment bien nous nous intéresser ici
mais sinon c'est sensiblement la même
chose on va avoir une nouvelle
technologie au niveau de la dame c'est
aussi un truc qui va venir nous
intéresser ici on passe du s20 de la
gamme s 20 avec une gamme qui s'appelait
les écrans en tout cas les dynamiques
amoled qui était plutôt cool sont
d'ailleurs toujours très cool
aujourd'hui sauf que là on a un écran
qui est un peu amélioré c'est le
dynamique amoled 2 x voilà y'a pas un
écart complètement dingos non plus on
est sur ce qu'on va appeler dans tous
ses modèles dans tous les modèles que je
vous présente un écran infiniti au alors
le infiniti haut pour vous resituer ne
soit pas très très compliqué en fait
c'est un écran qui perforait sur le
voyez pas en plein milieu vous avez le
trou c'est là c'est comme ça pour vous
dire mettre la caméra elle sera un peu
mieux intégré sur le s 21 sur le s20
c'est du point de détail mais malgré
tout le talent est là donc on a ça
effectivement
on va voir aussi une différence en
termes de performances on passe ici d'un
exil
os 990 à un exynos 2100 cécile nouvelle
génération donc on sait qu'on aura plus
de performances ça ira un peu plus vite
et on va voir une amélioration au niveau
de la photo mais on a quasiment les
mêmes configurations c'est à dire que
soient les modèles s 20 s 21 et le
modèle plus on va dire ça comme ça et
bien là vous avez une déclinaison deux
fois douze 12 mégapixels pense qu'on va
appeler votre grand-angle vous avez 12
mégapixels sur votre ultra-grand-angle
ça c'est très chouette et vous avez un
64 mégapixels pour votre téléobjectif
sensiblement la même chose je vous le
dis une fois de plus la différence que
vous allez avoir ici c'est le capteur
qui sera un peu plus grand que ça va
passer plus de lumière qui sera un peu
meilleur mais la recette reste
sensiblement la même
l'irc au niveau du s21 ultra que vous
avez un petit changement où vous allez
avoir double téléobjectif avec un x 3
optique et 1 x 10 optique qui vous
permettront effectivement remplacé la
jeu complètement en train d'écrire en
dehors du truc ça est complètement
ridicule ce qui vous permettra de venir
chercher plus loin d'être toujours cette
meilleure qualité avec un style zone
jusqu'à fois sans bon poisson va pas
très loin x 30 c'est déjà bien x 106
rigolo mais la qualité l épave donc
voilà un peu la différence voilà les
gros points de différence que vous allez
avoir il faut vraiment venir considérer
que les s-21 s-21 plus s res
ultra c'est une évolution ds 20s 20 plus
s20 ultra ya pas de gros changements il
n'y a rien de bien transcendant
ça évolue c'est mieux c'est plus joli il
ya une petite différence au niveau du
prix ça c'est un truc à connaître et à
comprendre c'est que en fait et ça se
fait surtout au niveau du r20 vers le s
ici une petite différence au niveau des
matériaux notamment au niveau du verre
vous avez plus un des records gorilla
glass 150 campings aurillac l'a6 que
vous aviez avant là nous ont changé ça
on se retrouve sur un dos en
polycarbonate c'est-à-dire d'eau en
plastique
on avait déjà le cas l'année dernière je
sais pas si vous soulevez au niveau du
nod 20 et notre vin il troque d'autres
vins ultra vous aviez un camping gorilla
glass virtus plus performant plus
résistant et a contrario l'autre côté
vous aviez également un dos en
polycarbonate moi je trouve ça pas
complètement dingue parce qu'on avait
l'impression de baisser en gamme dans le
très haut de gamme
ils ont conservé cette recette ici et ça
vous permet sans doute tiré un tarif qui
va être beaucoup plus bas sur le s 21
que l'était le s20 lorsqu'il est sorti
ce qui fait que s 21 est un produit
d'appel dans le haut de gamme
donc voilà pour ces modèles il y en a un
qui est au milieu qui est sorti deuxième
partie de l'année dernière c'est le s20
celui là est le s20 feu il est vachement
intéressant parce qu'en réalité ils à mi
chemin entre la gamme galaxy s 20 et la
gamme galaxy s 21
c'est à dire qu'en fait ici vous n'avez
pas une exigence ça c'est vraiment
différent pour le coup vous êtes ici sur
un snapdragon c'est un processeur de
qualcomm
c'est le processeur le plus puissant de
l'année dernière en gros c'est du
processeur qui était présentée fin 2019
pour l'année 2020 par qualcomm c'est le
895 995 us à 95 cents à 88 4 5 865 je
sais plus voilà 865 monsieur gros bug
avec tous ces chiffres 290 2100 soit 88
65 ans et plus 865 et ce qui est super
cool est ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est qu'en fait ce processeur la
processeur là il vous apportera beaucoup
de performances pour le traitement pour
le calcul il va être bon si pour
apporter de l'autonomie à votre
smartphone et pour la party gaming il
est hyper cool si vous avez les moyens
si vous avez les pépettes si vous avez
l'argent si vous avez de flouze vous
allez sur les samsung galaxy s 21
c'est ce qui ira le mieux ça marche très
très bien tout en sachant que l'ultra
c'est aujourd'hui à un instant t sur
2020 en tout cas le plus beau modèle
pouvez retrouver ces samsung vous avez
ici un écran wqs des plus vertes ou
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz vous avez
ce qui sera de mieux en terme de photos
vous irez une beaucoup plus loin enfin
bref c'est une super machine si
maintenant vous manqué un petit peu de
pépette et que vous rentrez pas dans le
budget le s20 ultra où les s20 plus
16-20 rêve pour moi encore en 2021 très
actuels sont d'excellents smartphones
maintenant il ya un autre truc il faut
venir voir c'est que sur le s20 et s20
plus vous aviez dernière deux
configurations je vous l'avais déjà dit
vous avez sur ces deux modèles une
version 4g et vous aviez également une
version 5 g nous allons pouvoir trouver
la version 4g moins cher que la version
5 gex sont reconditionnés neufs ou
d'occasion si vous pensez vraiment que
vous n'aurez jamais besoin de 5 g dans
les trois quatre ans à venir
et bien vous pouvez toujours aller sur
le s20 ici en version 4g qui vous
coûtera un peu moins cher qui peut être
assez intéressant
sinon moi ce que je vous conseillerais
quand même un volet en 2021 il faut se
projeter un peu vers l'avenir et si vous
êtes dans des villes ou en tout cas la 5
j arrive comme un smartphone 5g allons
maintenant on va se parler des usages
parce qu'effectivement regarder ça comme
ça c'est super intéressant
qu'est-ce qu'on va venir faire avec ses
smartphones alors comme je le disais la
gamme galaxy s on est sur une gamme qui
est axé sur la photo et sur la vidéo on
va donc se retrouver sur tous ses
modèles avec des
ils seront très très bon en termes de
photos et vidéos je vous le dis si vous
allez sur les modèles de 2020 s20 et d20
plus s20 ultra vous serez absolument pas
déçu en termes de photos termes de rendu
la qualité elle est superbe on a une
amélioration avec les s 21 et ce matin
un plus à ce matin ultra mais c'est une
amélioration il n'y a pas de grand
changement il ya rien de bec qui vous
fait dire waouh ça change pour venir
tirer un petit peu le budget allait sur
les hes 20s 20 + 16 à ultra sans
problème vous serez absolument pas déçu
maintenant il ya une différence avec le
l 20 f1 vous avez pas exactement les
mêmes capteurs c'est à dire vous allez
avoir sensiblement la même chose que
vous retrouver de l'autre côté
regardez on se mélange si je reprends ce
soit sur les hes 20 sur les s 21
vous avez un grand-angle un capteur
principal qui vaille de 12 mégapixels
vous avez un ultra grand angle de 12
mégapixels les capteurs vont être un
petit peu différent et améliorée avec le
s-21 donc on captera plus de lumière ils
seront meilleures pour les vautours
faible luminosité
mais ça nous raconte sensiblement la
même histoire sensiblement et vous avez
dans les deux cas un téléobjectif de 64
méga pixels et d'écouté si vous allez
sur le s20 et feu c'est presque la même
chose c'est à dire que tout ce qui va
être grand angle et ultra grand-angle
sur le feu et bien voulait retrouver
douze 12 vous l'avez le téléobjectif
c'est un peu différente et sur un 8
mégapixels
donc on dira un poil moins loin mais
l'idée est à peu près la même c'est à
dire que vous allez avoir un spectacle
zoom optique x 3 et vous monter jusqu'en
x 30 avec le space bull pour cette
configuration là donc il ya une petite
différence en termes de photos et ça me
paraît normal ce afin de tirer les
tarifs vers le map pas tout faire non
plus entre le s20 s-21 et le s20 f eu
tellement de modèles ça deviens
complètement dingue mais pour avoir
d'excellentes photos en conditions de
bonne luminosité en extérieur et même en
condition de nuit faible luminosité même
su revenir à moins loin qu'avec un s-21
frais compris l'histoire est bien le s20
et feuilles très cool et pour moi c'est
une super bonne option pour cette partie
là après il y aussi une différence que
vous allez retrouver notamment au niveau
des s20 et ds 21 je vous le dis c'est au
niveau de la vidéo ici préfère
effectivement de la nuit cas en 24
images par seconde c'est la même chose
l'autre côté mais est-ce que vous filmez
réellement oui car moi j'ai pas
convaincu la différence qui est
intéressant sur le s 21 est 21 h 21 ce
matin ils traquent vous n'aviez pas sur
le s20 c'est que vous pouvez faire de la
4k à 60 images par seconde
surtout les capteurs dont vous avez plus
de performance derrière grâce à l'exil
aux demies sens et la raison pour
laquelle vous pourriez faire ça quand
vous avez plus de puissance vous allez
également avoir un mode d'action cam qui
sera très cool avec de la stabilisation
c'est des petites différences c'est
différent ça sont liés à la capacité de
calcul de votre processeur exynos 2100
qui va être plus performant que le ca
dragonne 865 sera plus performant que
les casinos sur 190 que trouver sur les
samsung galaxy s vain toute la gamme de
l'année dernière donc on peut aller un
poil plus loin vous allez avoir aussi un
excellent smartphone avec beaucoup de
performance est très bon c'est pour
venir faire de la photo et de la vidéo
avec le s20 et feu c'est toujours après
une question de budget et quelle son
budget est une question de format parce
que sur le svs 21 vous avez un écran de
6,2 pouces
si vous êtes sur le s20 plus et le s 21
plus vous êtes sûr de 6 et 2,7 pouces
sans le s 21 ultra en 6 8 pouces et sur
le s20 ultra 6,9 pouces ce qui fait
qu'en réalité les tailles d'écran à
partir du plus jusqu'à l'ultra c'est
sensiblement la même chose en terme de
compacité s20 s-21 en termes de grands
écrans et confort de visionnage vous
partez sur le plus ou sur le modèle
ultra la grosse différence asseoir une
fois de plus en termes de définition ici
vous avez du wqs des plus et là vous
êtes sur du full hd + samsung vraiment
connu pour la qualité de ses dalles donc
pour la partie multimédia je vous dit
vraiment venir réfléchir ici surtout à
la taille de l'écran tout en sachant et
une fois de plus c'est à dire [ __ ] un
peu le bordel excusez moi c'est que si
vous arrivez sur le ffe et bien vous
êtes au milieu ici vous êtes sur un 6,5
pouces salses et samsung galaxy s 20 et
feu qui une fois de plus l'intermédiaire
entre ces modèles là et on retrouve une
fois de plus au niveau du format
bravo côté performances tous ses
smartphones sont vraiment très très bon
même si effectivement dit qu'un exynos
1990 avec moins bon qu'à l'exigence de
1100 et - mots quand un dragon 865 je
suis d'accord je suis d'accord mais ça
va concerner combien jeu quel
pourcentage de jeu peut-être un force
nike pousser à fond n'est encore donc
autant vous dire que vous posez pas trop
la question ça dépend de votre exigence
dans les jeux ça dépend de pas mal de
choses mais pour moi tous ces
smartphones sont vraiment excellents
pour des métaux de rafraîchissement de
120 m
de tous les côtés vous allez
effectivement avoir toute la gamme s
vente qui va être moins performante que
le s20 et feu même si c'est le modèle je
fais un peu cheap local moins cher et
qui va être moins performant qu'un s 21
c'est normal donc si vous voulez ce qui
se fait de mieux en terme de performance
aujourd'hui s 21 mais si vous allez sur
sv feu pour le gaming pas de problème je
vous dis une fois de plus s'en va et ça
marche bien on a tout ce qu'il faut
l'autonomie est bonne
l'autonomie c'est moi qui ai aussi
extrêmement important en question
autonomie dans les trois cas ça marchera
bien parce que vous avez des processeurs
qui vont très bien venir gérer
l'autonomie plus vous allez venir monter
avec un smartphone notamment les ultras
et plus vous aurez une grosse batterie
5000 millan peur dans le cas du ultra
mais que ce soit dans un cas ou dans
l'autre autonomie est bien géré ça va
dépendre pas plus de vous de vos usages
de ce que vous allez en faire il ya un
autre point avec moi qui est assez
intéressant ça c'est très très très
riche est vraiment au point qui est
extrêmement dit chez je suis obligé de
le préciser parce que je vous parle
effectivement du tout ses smartphones là
c'est sur le samsung galaxy s 21
ultra et uniquement sur le samsung
galaxy s 21 ultra samsung nous a fait
une petite blague comme il aime bien
faire à la croisée des chemins et bien
vous avez ici la possibilité de mettre
un s pen qu'est ce que le s pen si vous
ne savez pas le s pen s'est instillé
c'est le style et de samsø vous
retrouvez notamment pour la gamme note
la gagne au tournoi par une prochaine
fois que vous retrouvez également sur
les tablettes
alors vous aurez pas les airs jester
parce que tout ce qui va être bluetooth
on commande avec vous ne l'aurez pas
maintenant ce qui va m'intéresser c'est
la question du prix es21 vous pouvez le
trouver à 859 euros ça qui est vachement
intéressant c'est qu'en fait le s20 des
plus chères à la même période
et vous voyez dès qu'on arrive ensuite
sur le s 21 plus 1109 euros le s 21
ultra 1439 euros sur des gros budget et
très très gros budget quand vous
regardez ce qu'ils avaient l'année
dernière le s20 peut le trouver entre
600 à 730 euros entre du ou
reconditionnés entre d'autres revendeurs
on peut aussi la trouvais pas trop trop
cher maintenant est ce que ça vaut le
coup il a acheté 730 euros alors vous
avez un s 21 à 8 159 euros
pour moi la réponse est non c'est pour
ça que si vous vous dites que le s20
peut vous intéresser
ça vaut quand même le coup de se poser
la question du s21 regarder si vous
voulez vraiment intéressant est ce qu'il
est 4g et 5g parce que si sur le s 21
vous êtes 5g uniquement 5 g après je
sais pas quel moment vous avez cette
vidéo dans l'année mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que les tarifs ont baissé un petit
peu ils vont pas s'effondrer mais vous
baisser un petit peu c'est donc pas
potentiellement trouver un peu moins
cher que 859 euros donc ça peut aussi
être un très bon plan contrario si vous
l'achetez wright 20 plus paradis je me
trouvais en tout 700 euros aujourd'hui
contre
ils 109 euros sur un ace 21 plus ça va
dépendre une fois de plus si c'est un
modèle 4g et 5g il faut mettre tous en
perspective et puis le dernier c'est
l'ultra dans l'ultra jetant tout ça
c'est sympa j'ai trouvé à 850 euros le
s20 ultra c'est vraiment bien on est sur
un smartphone singer quoi qu'il se passe
le ultra et 5 g contre eux 1439 euros
sur le s 21 ultra donc je pense que si
vous voulez acheter un modèle ultra et
vous avez les moyens vous voulez le plus
gros l'ultra le haut de gamme et
compagnie eh bien je pense que le s 21
ultra il est fait pour vous mais si vous
voulez ce qui se fait de mieux avec les
ultras et le space une fois sans vous
voulez capteurs 108 mégapixels mais vous
n'avez pas 1400 vous voulez pas mettre
1400 euros 60 ans complètement eh bien
regardez que le s20 ultras qui pour moi
n'a pas pris une gifle et reste vraiment
extrêmement bien positionnée et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le meilleur rapport qualité prix
c'est ce fameux samsung galaxy s 20 f e
vous pouvez le trouver en version 4g et
même sur le site de samsung aujourd'hui
à 659 euros et en version 5 g à 759
euros et vous réussirez à le trouver sur
internet si vous cherchez dernière je
vous mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description aux alentours des 500 euros
ce qui fait qu'en fait vous avez un
samsung de la gamme s qui n'est pas
anciens qui est un processeur qui est
très performant qui sera un peu moins
bon au niveau du téléobjectif mais qui
fait très bonne photo avec le
grand-angle et l' ultra grand angle qui
aura un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
ya ce qu'on a surtout une dalle samsung
maîtriser qu'un écran infiniti au une
dalle super amoled
bref aujourd'hui c'est pour moi en tout
cas tout de suite en 2021 à l'heure à
laquelle je trouve cette vidéo le
meilleur rapport qualité prix c'est le
samsung galaxy s 20-f que les autres
sont cool mais celui là il est très bon
une fois de plus en terme de taille
d'écran île à mi-chemin 6,5 pouces entre
le 6,2 et de 6,7 il vraiment à mi-chemin
en termes de photos il fait tout sans
trop en faire en terme de performance
il ya vraiment ce qu'ils font à
l'intérieur il a une très bonne
autonomie sera très bon pour lui mais il
sera un très bon pour tous à du wifi si
ça pour moi aujourd'hui si je dois
conseiller un meilleur rapport qualité
prix au niveau de la gamme s c'est le
samsung galaxy s 20 et feu sans
discussion après si vous voulez plus
vous voulez aller plus loin notamment
avec un tel objectif
le s 21 reste quand même très bien
positionné à 859 euros et peut être un
petit peu moins au courant de l'année le
s20 du coup il va être éclipsés par ce
modèle là parce que même s'il est moins
cher le lez
et bien il n'y a pas un gap qui énorme
donc ça vaut le coup d'aller sur le s 21
parce que vous prendrez moins d'argent
que si vous achetez un ace 20 à 700 750
euros par rapport à un ace 21 a eu dans
59 euros notamment au prix de revente et
si vous voulez le roman noir conditions
donc ça ça nous vraiment coup maintenant
le s-21 plus soleil levant plus la
question se pose en ici de la taille de
l'écran on a exactement la même chose en
terme de photos entre les 21 et ce matin
+ 16 20 s20 plus c'est la même chose
juste le capteur qui va changer un petit
peu nous expliquer la performance qui va
forcément permet d'aller un poil plus
loin et si vous voulez ce qui serait
mieux le ultra voilà les ultras ça
dépend de votre bourse
voilà j'espère que vous aurez et d'essai
dans sa chaussée c'est très très très
dense 1 il ya tellement de choses à
raconter et là dessus tous les côtés les
processeurs la photo le style ça ça fait
beaucoup
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire lequel vous fait de
l'oeil ghana vous fait de l'oeil alors
pas du tout et est ce que vous en avez
acheté un j'anticipe la question aux
commentaires j'ai achetée un samsung
galaxy s 20 l'année dernière elle est ce
que je dois acheter les 21 noms gars ne
le vois pas changer tous les ans penser
à la planète
nom de zeus voilà c'est pas ça vous
intéresser des webisodes de l'amour ils
vous envoient beaucoup de tendresse moi
beaucoup de tendresse et pour moi c'est
cadeau pour les soins et soutien
vous allez retrouver également
[Musique]